there hasn't been much snow for the
Northeast the region is now getting hit
by the biggest storm of the season on
the final day of the last full month of
winter
meanwhile near the Great Lakes where
residents typically expect snow the
region is covered in ice from freezing
rain it was a big snowstorm last week
and it's raining today I never know what
to wear outside anymore it's horrible
part of the same system that began with
rare blizzards in Southern California
before unleashing 110 mile per hour
winds in the Southern Plains University
of Oklahoma football player Corey
robison's home was destroyed by a
tornado he and his sister hid in a
bathtub when it roared through his
teammates showing up the next day to
help clean up but just as these storms
begin to exit the East another Coast to
Coast system is brewing in the West